nadège vous êtes sur place il ya du
monde semble-t-il la mobilisation a été
entendue écoutée grégory leçon à
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
avoir répondu présent à ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui devant le sénat à l'occasion
de l'examen de ce projet de loi de
sécurité globale quatre mois après son
examen par l'assemblée nationale trois
mois après son sassa validation alors
ils sont plusieurs centaines
ici sur place et par les esea
manifestants on retrouve des
journalistes des avocats ou encore des
membres d'associations de
des droits humains je propose d'être
dans l'écouté quelques-uns au sénat il
ya des risques sérieux que les
intentions du gouvernement soit alourdi
encore par la majorité de droite et que
la droite joigne ses voix à celles du
gouvernement pour faire ressortir du
sénat un texte aggraver encore par par
rapport à celui qui avait été adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale et le continuum de
sécurité dont parle gérald darmanin nous
inquiète parce que il comporte un volet
très important aussi de prix de
privatisation progressive à des missions
de sécurité publique au profit des
polices municipales et des polices
privées
c'est un texte extrêmement attentatoires
sur les libertés au sens large c'est une
atteinte sans précédent sur nos libertés
fondamentales est également une atteinte
à la liberté d'informer et d'être
informé qui risque d'être entravée
demain en raison de cette proposition de
loi et les sénateurs ont amendé une
partie du texte notamment l'article 24
qui a été réécrit mais ce n'est toujours
pas suffisant sur une provocation à
l'identification qui ne va rien résoudre
du tout puisque des gardes à vue ou
arrestations arbitraires encore avoir
lieu et parmi les articles les plus
décriés de ce projet de loi figure
l'article 22 relatif à l usage et des
drones par les autorités l'article 24 1
qui punit de 45000 euros d'amendé d'un
an de prison tout dit
dion malveillantes d'image des forces de
l'ordre alors pour les manifestants la
majorité des manifestants présents ici
ce texte ce projet de loi de sécurité
globale et un texte
qualifiée de liberticide et bouquet
c'est interdire qu'il existe des images
controversées dans un état de droit
interdire qu'on puisse dénoncer
certaines actions sous prétexte qu'elles
sont du côté de l'ordre
du côté de la
du pouvoir et donc c'est un moyen parmi
d'autres de nous de nous faire taire et
de windows auprès d'eux nous opprimer
quoi en fait c'est un message d'impunité
qui est donnée de plus en plus à la
police et à tout ce qu'on a vu ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers temps et avec
eux de plus en plus en fait de
démonstration devancé de dollars us mais
du coup de moins en moins de
possibilités en fait ces 18 mois et vous
devriez peut-être vers des manifestants
qui est un des slogans hostiles au
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron hostiles
à cette loi de sécurité globale des
manifestants qui y est bien aussi allumé
à d
me gêne pour le moment
plutôt calmé et joyeuse et s'il veut lui
dire ses textes de sécurité globale
4-1 examiné à partir d'aujourd'hui merci
nadège abderrazak en direct donc du
palais du luxembourg où se poursuit
cette manifestation